Багато я знаю людей, які засуджують, казали:
"Ти мама, лишила дитину, як ти могла!"
Свій вибір я зробила. І я про нього аж ніяк не шкодую.
Це Анастасія Савка. Друге ім'я їй дали побратими в ЗСУ - "Фенікс".
Жінка взяла снайперську гвинтівку до рук у 23 роки,
аби захищати Україну від російського вторгнення,
пережила тяжкі бої на передовій і втратила частину ноги.
Але у неї є виправдана ціль, каже жінка: боротьба з окупантами
заради майбутнього свого сина Яреми. Поки Анастасія дає інтерв'ю DW,
5-річний хлопчик безтурботно грається поруч.
Але добре розуміє, що сталося з його мамою.
Мама стала на міну.
Такий рушник, що ставиться на ногу.
Щоб нога просто не боліла.
Яремі було 3 роки, коли РФ вторглася в Україну в лютому 22-го.
Тоді вони жили у Львові. Анастасія, яка працювала адміністраторкою
у автосервісі, одразу вирішила: покине роботу і піде до лав ЗСУ.
Жодного армійського досвіду у жінки не було.
Спочатку не брали жінок взагалі, тобто навіть не всіх чоловіків,
тому що був наплив дуже сильний, якщо ви пам'ятаєте.
Коли почалася повномасштабна війна, і була реально загроза.
Загроза для нас, для наших дітей.
І вже не було думки про андреналін, про те, що я хочу чи не хочу.
Ну, треба вставати і щось робити!
Я не хочу, щоб потім моя дитина мала брати в руки зброю.
Доки за маленьким Яремою наглядали батьки Анастасії,
увесь вільний час вона проводила на курсах зі стрільби
для цивільних у Львові. Там зацікавилася снайперською гвинтівкою
і опанувала її за пів року, перш ніж жінку офіційно прийняли
до лав Збройних Сил. Навіть після вишколу, каже Анастасія,
чоловіки у ЗСУ спершу скептично ставилися до її бажання служити.
Та як інакше, ви що?! Це ж до дівчат в армії ще ставлення немає
такого, щоб їх сприймали. Тобто їх починають сприймати,
це вже коли пройдуть якийсь етап з ними, вже коли зрозуміють,
що вони дійсно щось можуть, хочуть, розуміють.
Спочатку такого, звичайно, нема: до тебе ставляться,
як до жінки, як до слабкої.
Під час бойових завдань на Запорізькому напрямку, куди влітку торік
відправили служити Анастасію, жінка проявила свої здібності.
Скепсис, який чоловіки проявляли на початку, швидко замінила повага.
Втім, легко не було ніколи.
Ти собі лежиш, дивишся в оптику, як у фільмі, збоку можеш собі
каву поставити. Ні! Ні! Це все не так, як у фільмі!
Насправді ніколи не було зручних позицій як для снайпера.
Тобто завжди було це з коліна, сперта до дерева, на колінах.
Ти окопуєшся під обстрілом. Якщо близькі прильоти,
тебе засипає землею, ми один одного розкопуємо.
Восени 2023-го року Анастасія із бригадою щоденно
відбивали штурми армії РФ.
У листопаді одна з місій закінчилася для неї трагічно.
Прильоти вже були такі прям, реально, я вже реально думала,
що все, тут ми лишимось. І до нас виходять на рацію,
щоб ми відтягнулися з тої позиції трохи далі.
Я стаю у воронку, і просто відчуваю такий струм по всьому тілу,
від ніг просто до голови, сильний запах тротилу в носі.
У мене вже оця нога… я вже чітко розуміла, що там ампутація.
Доки Анастасію везли до стабпункту, а звідти - у запорізьку лікарню,
жінка лишалася при тямі. Каже, усе, про що думала, - це син і батьки…
Нині Ярема з Анастасією прийшли разом у реабілітаційний центр у Львові:
тут мама готується опанувати перший протез, а син - підтримує її.
Ми зараз приходимо, щоб мама проходила реабілітацію, тренувалася.
Ти ж так само хочеш тренуватися? Cпортом займатися?
А я отак тренуюсь!
Він каже: "А ти знаєш, чого ти на міну наступила?" Я кажу: "Чого?"
Думаю, що він скаже? Він такий: "Треба під ноги дивитись!"
Він не соромиться спитатися все, як є.
Після двох тижнів першого етапу реабілітації у центрі "Superhumans"
Анастасію вже впізнають у коридорах: захисниця з символічним
позивним "Фенікс" вражає лікарів темпами
відновлення заради нового життя.
Анастасія дуже наполегливо старається.
Не було якогось сперечання. На початку першого тренування
я дав занадто легкі вправи.
Чесно, думала, буде гірше. Ну, типу, довго лежати...
Але я якось вхожу в ритм! Мені ще бігати і бігати!
Відсутність частини ноги - не перепона і для плавання.
Навпаки - ще один з викликів для Анастасії.
У басейні жінка тренує м'язи, аби по-новому ходити з протезом.
Анастасія, як тільки зайшла, в принципі, навіть не видно,
що це є пацієнтка з ампутацією. Тому що плаває вона досить класно.
За відновленням Анастасії з цікавістю і захопленням спостерігають
інші ветерани у цьому центрі.
Чесно кажучи, це перша дівчина, яку я побачив з бойовою травмою.
Коли дивишся на цивільних мужиків, які по два метри зростом,
два метри шириною - і не йдуть захищати країну.
А дівчата метр п'ятдесят зростом, худенька, маленька -
і вона з автоматом десь бігає. Ну, то є, звісно, захоплення такими.
Я не агітую, щоб всі жінки пішли в армію.
Просто треба розуміти, що ми не в казці, що війна так от дивним дивом
не закінчиться. Настане період, коли доведеться всім бути готовими.
Анастасія протягом найближчих місяців планує повністю
відмовитися від візка. Її наступна ціль: повернутися на фронт.
Каже, надто багато віддала службі, аби зараз просто піти.
Коли мені хтось писав: "Для тебе війна закінчилась".
Я така: та ні! Вона не може для мене закінчитися! Ну, як закінчилась?
Ну, ні для кого, мені здається, не закінчилась!
Син Ярема про плани мами повернутися у військо ще не знає.
Наразі обоє просто насолоджуються часом удвох:
за іграми і підготовкою хлопчика до першого класу в школі.
Хлопчик зацікавився плаванням, бо побачив,
що мама займається цим спортом.
Потім ми з тобою підемо?
- Плавати? - Ну так!